we're now going to do a few example
questions from the Khan Academy exercise
on the standard algorithm so we're asked
which of the following correctly
multiplies 74 times 8 using the standard
algorithm so pause this video and see if
you can work on that before we do it
together all right now let's just remind
ourselves what the standard algorithm is
and in fact let's just remind ourselves
what an algorithm is an algorithm is a
series of steps that you can do to do
something so you'll often hear about a
computer algorithm but you could also
have algorithms and math just a method
for doing something and the standard of
the group the standard algorithm that's
the typical or the standard way that a
lot of people will tackle a
multiplication question or computation
like this but just as a reminder in the
standard algorithm if we're multiplying
seventy four times eight we would write
the eight in the ones place right below
the four in the ones place and then you
multiply each of these places times the
eight so you would start with the four
times the eight you would get 32 32 you
can express as two ones and three tens
so you'll put that 3 up there and then
you would multiply the 7 times the eight
seven times eight is fifty-six and
that's going to be 56 tens because it's
seven tens times eight is fifty-six tens
plus the three tens you had before get
you 259 tens and so you would write over
here that's fifty nine tens and so this
would be 592 now when you look at the
choices that's exactly what happened
here in choice C just for kicks we can
see what went wrong in these other ones
to see in this first one when we
multiplied the when we multiplied the
four ones times eight ones according to
this this person somehow got three ones
and two tens and twenty three four times
eight is not twenty three you could rule
that one out
and here when they multiplied the four
ones times the eight ones that would be
32 that so it's two ones and then
another three
hands so sure there should have been a
three up here and so that way when you
multiply the seven tens times eight you
get 56 but then you have this other
three ten so you would really need to
get 259 tens so that's one that's why
that one didn't work let's do another
example here and this is going to be
with a different type of question so
here we are told that Don starts to use
the standard algorithm to solve 418
times five his work is shown below what
number should Don replace Y with pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out okay so the way to think about this
this might at first confuse you a little
bit because why and why is there a y
there did it in the first place but what
they're really trying to get at is
making sure that you or we understand
what Don is trying to do when he's
trying to do the standard algorithm so
as we just highlighted in the last
example the way that we would tackle
this with the standard algorithm it'll
actually me write down 418 times 5 we
would say eight ones times five ones is
going to be 40 ones 40 ones we could
write as zero ones and four tens and so
that looks like the place where they
were Don stopped computing so he's on
his way to solving the whole thing he's
just partially computed it so far but
just by doing that we know what the the
Y should be the Y should be four so what
number should Don replace the Y with
should he should replace it with a four
and it's representing Y tens or four
tens and of course you could keep going
with this computation if Don were then
to say okay I have 110 times 5 that
would be five tens plus another four
tens that's nine tens and then last but
not least if Don wanted to figure out
well he's got four hundreds here times
five is 2000s which you can express as
zero hundreds and 2000s or you could
just view this as 2000s so they're not
asking us to do the entire computation
we're just trying to figure out what Don
did essentially in this first step what
number should Eve written here instead
of a Y so Y could be replaced with the
four it's
presenting the four which is really in
the tens place before tens